yesterday your Hancock from kth and you
don't tell us about they are hot
formulas thank you very much for the
introduction and yeah thanks to the
organizer for the invitation to speak
here it's a really great opportunity
yeah I'm gonna speak about 1/2
polynomials of dilated koala tops that's
what it said in the program and then I
realized I actually have a bit more time
so I will also tell you a bit about
zonal tops and let me start by
introducing our main objects which are
lattice polytopes so lattice polytopes
at a convex hull of Heineken many points
in the integer lattice and typically I'm
interested in counting the number of
lattice points in such polytopes so the
number of lattice points it's also
called a discrete volume because it
shares a couple of properties mr. usual
euclidean volume and typically i'm not
only interested in the number of lattice
points of the polytope itself but also
what happens with this number under
integer dilations so if you look at this
example here we have a unit square in
the plane we have four lattice points in
there if we're dilated by a factor of
two we can easily count its nine number
nine the number of lattice points 16 and
so on so we easily see that the number
of lattice points in the ends dilate
where n is an integer is n plus 1
squared and since this is a workshop
within the geometry of polynomials
program I think I hope we can all agree
that this is a really nice function and
n named your polynomial and well it
turns out that this is not just true for
unit squares in the plane but much more
general the basic theorem of well what
is called air hats Yui is that this
happens whenever you start with an
arbitrary lattice polytope and in an
arbitrary Euclidean space are 2d so the
number of lattice points and the ants
dilate of a polytope is given by
polynomial and recreates the dimension
of the polygon
this polynomial is called the air high
polynomial P and it appears at a variety
of places and community oryx and algebra
very naturally so for example if you
wanna count graph colorings given a
fixed graph and you wanna count the
number of graph colorings for a given
number of colors than this given by a
polynomial one can see this by a air hat
theory or one can see also that this
happen Omiya is a Hilbert function of
graded algebra which can be naturally
assigned to the lattice polytope and so
there's a fruitful interplay between
Erhard theory and commutative algebra in
particular and essential question air
had serious like can we characterize air
her polynomial so what makes a
polynomial and air happen Omiya and
closely related to that can be interpret
the coefficients so i already well I
think oats a variety of properties for
sure like we already know that the
degree of the polynomial is the
dimension of the polytope but then it
coats more so for example the leading
coefficient is always the volume the
second highest coefficient is related to
the surface area the constant
coefficient is one but that's actually
mostly what we know about these
polynomials and one reason is that the
interpretation of the coefficient is
difficult because in general these
coefficients can be negative and this
already happens in dimension 3 so in
fact one can show that every other
coefficient apart from the leading the
second highest and a constant can be can
be negative and yeah that's kind of a
problem for interpretation so an
important tool to study this air - no
mrs. D I had serious so what is that
well we take this generating series over
the number of lattice points and since
it's a polynomials or EP n was the
number of lattice points and ends dilate
we can write it as a rational function
and numerator we have a polynomial of
degree D if did of degree at most D F D
was the dimension of the polytope and
then denominator we have one minus T to
the D plus one and so this numerator
polynomial is called the HDI polynomial
of the polytope P and so why is this
numerator polynomial interesting well it
encodes as our era polynomial in a
different basis so if we look at the
vector space of polynomials of degree at
most D then we can also look at the
basis N + D to Steve and plus D minus 1
to C and so on and they're coordinates
of the air have polynomial in this basis
are exactly given by the coefficients of
the HTR polynomial and these H star
polynomials have much nicer properties
so in particular the coefficients are
all non-negative this is a theorem by
Stanley and he actually also showed that
there are non-negative integers so as
combinatorial Asst this is great for us
because now we want to count something
so we want to find interpretations but
its numbers actually means something
coming at orally or at least we want to
want to characterize and restrict the
number the possible H star polynomials
so non negativity is kind of the easiest
inequalities that you can haven't
there's a variety of other inequalities
that are known for arbitrary polytopes
and so this is one direction of study
studying H star polynomials for
arbitrary polytopes
inequalities of them and add a question
include well what geometric or
comunitaria properties imply certain
inequalities that might not be true for
all lattice polytopes but maybe for
interesting subclasses and so one
property that is of particular interest
is you
modality us a very natural property so
you know modality means you first your
sequence first rises to a certain point
and then your stun but in particular it
does not have any any tips and so today
well today we want to talk about your
modality of HDR polynomials for certain
class of polytopes and you know modality
is typically kind of hard to prove
yes know that that's typically yeah
quite hard to prove and but there's
other properties that are stronger that
oftentimes seem to be easier to prove
and one of them is slow concavity so if
you have a lot concave sequence and
which doesn't have internal zeros then
you're automatically our Euler model and
even stronger if you have a real rooted
polynomial then the coefficients for my
you know model sequence if the
coefficients are non-negative okay and
so today we will see two class of
polynomials whether it's that
polynomials I rebooted that polytopes
whether it's that part numbers every
good and the first question that also
announced in the abstract was well
imagine you have a lattice polytope then
it's very natural to ask well how does
the h star pretty normally behave if you
dilate your lattice polytope yeah I mean
it start putting on me but also change
so how does this behave and this is
what's a question that was studied by a
couple of people like plenty very
diaconis woman back it's day button who
all could see that after the dilation
factor becomes when the dilation factor
becomes large and this H star polynomial
becomes rebooted in fact it converges to
the Alerian polynomial and beckons day
button indeed gave a uniform bound that
only depends on the dimension but and
not on the polytope itself and they also
conjectured that the one bound would be
you just have to dilate by
a factor at least dimension of D and
what I want to show today is so that's
the conjecture is true and that you can
actually give even a better bound so you
just have to dilate by a factor that is
bigger than the original degree of the H
star polynomial so that H toponymy of
the original polytope start so this is
the first thing in that I want to show
and as I said since I also have a bit
more time I also want to talk about
lettuce Ponyta allows longer tops and
pilot pipettes yes yes yes so yeah it's
on top so what are zona tops so for the
purpose of this talk a ladder stone atop
generated by lattice points we want to
be K it's simple simply the set of all
linear combinations lambda some of the
llama IV I by lambda between 0 and 1 so
I'll turn ative Li you can also define
this as I mean coughs the sum of the
segments between 0 and VI and while a
special subclass Blair's peril pipettes
this is what you obtain when you start
with the whisk a independent linearly
independent vectors then you get a
parrot pilot and for this power pipettes
sheperson from Langevin proved that the
H star polynomial is always your model
for the parrot pilots and so together
with Matthias Peck and Emily McCauley
from San Francisco State I could
generalize the Stearman to lattice toner
tops and be proved not only on mortality
but also rebooted nests and could give
an interpretation of the coefficients
and so so today I want to show you how
we get rebooted best for the solo tops
and also for these dilated simplices
and both of these classes fit into well
abide our context namely that of
so-called IDP polytopes so what is an
IDP polytope well an IDP polytope has
the following property for every integer
n and every lattice point and the ends
dial it of your poly tope yes n lattice
point and points and original polytopes
that if you send them up you obtain this
point so it's always true that you can
find arbitrary points and your original
polytope but that you find integer point
is really something a bit more special
and so far this IDP polytopes there's
like a intensely studied I would say
conjecture around and I had Siri which
is usually referred to Stanley but
actually was also stated in the one or
other way by many other people namely
whenever you have such an IDP polytope
then the edge type anomia has unimodel
coefficients and we actually don't even
know if they're not even they could even
be locked ok so and so important so the
most important IDP polytope is probably
a you know modular simplex so you know
model the simplex is a simplex of
minimal volume 1 over D factorial
equivalently you can define it as the
vertices are finally spandy integer
lives and to discuss of other people it
helps us Rd there's all the tops belong
so and also the pile pepper so for power
pipe it's actually not too hard to see
so a power paper test this really nice
property that if you take an integer
dial eight of your power pipe it then it
can be tired with copies of your
original polytope and that's why one can
it's not so hard to see do to obtain the
integer decomposition property
and some tops have this really beautiful
property which was first realized by my
shepherd that you can tile it by
parallel pipe it's now and so if you
have a union of IDP polytopes then the
polytope is again IDP it's also so no
tops are IDP and it was shown by a bouns
go ballots and cook that also if you
dial and start with an arbitrary lattice
polytopes and take a large dilate that
it becomes IDP so they gave a bount of
dimension of P minus 1 so when they take
a larger dilation factor then you're
automatically IDP so in that sense these
two classes of example that I want to
show you fit on to this context okay so
what they want to do so I first want to
talk quickly about interlacing
polynomials I guess many of you you
might already know this concept and then
we want to apply results there to
lettuce on tops and dilated
that's proposed okay so what are
intelligent polynomials so imagine you
have two polynomials F and G and F has
roots as one to escape as one to as M
and G has roots if you want to TN so
real roots really polynomials and we say
that F interlaces G whenever the roots
are ordered in this way so the biggest
food is good of of G the second one is
the root of F and so on and so forth
and so from the definition and follows
immediately that I mean the interlacing
property doesn't change if you multiply
our polynomials with real numbers and it
also follows that the degrees of these
polynomials are not so far apart and the
most interesting property is probably
that any linear combination of these
polynomials is also reroute so it's not
hard to see and actually follows quite
easily from the intermediate value
theorem okay
and we are not only interested in
interlacing polynomials but an
interlacing sequence of polynomials so a
sequence of polynomials F 1 to F n is
called interlacing if fi interlaced F J
whenever I small equal to J and these
polynomials have a variety of really
beautiful properties and one of well
probably one of the most important one
is that so assuming that the leading to
leading coefficients are all the same
that say they are positive then any
non-negative linear combination will be
rooted and yeah so this this property is
it's the key property that people that
you want to use
and so now I hope I already convinced
you that interlacing polynomials are
great but now the question is how do we
get them and so one way to to to get
interlacing polynomials is inductively
so imagine you have you have a sequence
of interlacing polynomials F 1 2 F M and
here we need to assume that all the
coefficients are non-negative
equivalently that all the roots are
negative then we can construct a new
sequence of interlacing polynomials in
this way here so G L is T times F 1 and
so on T times F L minus 1 plus F L plus
and so on J so this this recursion was
used by Savage and Basanti when they
looked at so-called s or Larian
polynomials but can also be found in
like a printable preliminary draft of a
book off of this and so using these
elementary properties that have shown
you before and the fact that they have
non-negative coefficients it's actually
not hard to see that actually true it's
really just induction and as as an
observation the sequence T 1 T 2 2 GN
plus 1 depends linearly on that on the
sequence F 1 F 2 F M namely we can
multiply the sequence with this matrix
of polynomials yeah and so patter
brandine actually provided a complete
characterization of all such matrices
that preserve interlacing of sequences
with non-negative coefficients
so for the purpose of this talk keep
this matrix in mind okay so now then
let's that was latest on the tops so as
I said so the key property that we want
to use is that we can is this that
non-negative linear combinations of
interlacing polynomials give every rule
a polynomial yeah and so what we want to
do so for that purpose I mean
non-negative linear combination so how
do we calculate error polynomial so I
mean a naive way is like start with a
polytope dissect it into some simpler
polytopes then you know it for the
simpler parts and then do inclusion
exclusion but inclusion exclusion is a
bit well it's not very practical if you
want to show that something is a
non-negative linear combination so what
you'd want to do instead you want to
have like kind of a real partition of
your polytope so no intersections so you
don't have to do inclusion exclusion and
so one way to do is well you start with
with a subdivision of your poly tope in
this case a solo top and so now we know
that by this result of shepard we can
dissect our solo top in two parallel
pipes and now we take a generic point
inside this solo top and we view this
point as a light source and now we take
any maximal cell and the subdivision and
look at which which facets can be seen
from this light source and take away
these facets so for example if we look
at this maximal cell here
then what point would so which passes
would I see from this point here well I
would see this facet here and this year
yeah
and here in this picture I remove those
and I do this for every Maxima cell and
I can see that this actually gives you a
partition of of yours on the top and to
half-open peril Pipers okay and these
half of empower pilots have a really
nice property namely because I'm in
power pipettes
every power pipe that has always two
parallel facets right and for each like
it can never happen that both of these
parallel pipe it's at both of these
parallel facets are removed now so
because it's a imagine just points a
light source you can either see this
side or you can see this side or maybe
none of them but not both at the same
time and so prototypically it turns out
that all these half of power pipettes
are comet or equivalent to half open
unit cubes by which I mean like I take a
unit tube and I remove coordinate
hyperplanes and so the first step would
be to understand this half half of
Munich oops what are the H star
polynomials because then in the end if
you understand like the basic ideas if
you understand it's double enormous of
these half-open power pipettes
then in the end you just have to send
them all up and then we're done so first
step is to understand this half of unit
tubes and so they start for the normal
of these half of munich troops is
actually quite well known and it's
related to the alare numbers or Larian
polynomials so what are those so look at
the permutations on D letters and let's
say Sigma such a permutation then an
index I is called a descent of the
permutation if Sigma of I is greater
than Sigma of I plus 1
so is mapped to something bigger than I
plus one and now if you act over all
permutations and your permutations in
your permutation SD T to the number of
the descents then this is what is called
a velarium polynomial so as an example
we have this permutation here so 1 is
mapped to 2 2 is mapped to three three
years mapped to 1 then to us at this end
because 2 is mapped to 3 but 3 is mapped
to 1 which is smaller
yeah and so in this example here I mean
on we have 6 permutations on 3 letters
and here only brought down the second
line and I marked the descent the
position of the ascent in red then we
see we have one permutation with zero
descends for permutations with one
descent and two permutations were to
descent ok and it so this alarum
polynomials appear very often coming at
works and they are known to be rebooted
and there's a variety of proofs and
apparently was already known to fobian
your sentences only weirwoods and so how
do we see now that this the Alerian
polynomials gives you the H star
polynomial of the of the unit cube for
that you have to believe me something
namely what is the h ee na mele often a
half-open unimodular simplex so if I
don't like a habit unimodular simplex
if I don't remove any facet then the H
star polynomials 1 and much annually if
I remove a facets then H star polynomial
is T to the I so T to the number of
removed facets so and if you it's
actually not not very hard to see that
would require some calculation and but
if you believe me this for now then I
hope to be able to explain to you how we
get the H star polynomial of the unit
cube
for example yeah yeah it it's yeah good
boy yeah
okay um so what do we do with you nubs
well now we understand you know modular
simplices so what about we dissect it
into your model or simplices
and so one way is like okay take a
generic point so I will just try to
describe to you a triangulation and -
you know modular simplices take a
generic point in your poly tope and
order its coordinates yeah and this
gives you a permutation of the
coordinates and I'll take all generic
points that give you the same
permutation and this will give you the
interior of such a maximal cell so this
is the this is a triangulation until you
know modular simply sees this atom the
maximal cells and now as I said like
it's really impractical to do inclusion
exclusion so let's do it half openly and
one can do it half openly by saying well
I get strict inequality whenever I have
a dis out and actually it also comes
from such a decomposition by taking a
generic point and a cell that belongs to
the identity so I can see that okay and
now the only thing that we have to do
well the H star putting on of the unit
cube is the sum of the HDI polynomial of
the you know model simply sees the
half-open ones and for the half of
months to understand what it is it's a
number of removed facets but a number of
removed facets is exactly the number of
the dissents and that's how how we get
to edged up you know after you
okay and so for half of Munich oops so
where we move code and hyperplanes it
works actually exactly the same so you
can take the same decomposition the same
half-open decomposition and again count
the number of facets that were removed
in such a half-open
simplex the only singers now sometimes
more facets are removed and when when
does this happen so let's say I remove
the first J hyperplanes
the first a coordinate hyperplanes well
then if I'm in a cell and Sigma 1 is
smaller equal to j then you get like
here a strict inequality so you get an
additional design so to say so let's
call this for the moment the J dissent
statistic which says well it's just a
descent if your permutation starts with
a letter that's bigger than J oh it's
this ain't the usual descent plus one if
it's smaller equal to J and so when one
can write us down a bit nicely so this
in fact the set of permutation with J
descends equal to K isn't rejection with
the permutations on D plus one letters
with descent K and starting regular J
plus one so what's the idea well proof
by example let's say we have D equals
five letters and we have J equals 3
which means like a permutation that
starts with a letter 1 2 or 3 gets an
additional descent so how can you can
assimilate this by looking at
permutations on D plus 1 letters well I
just put a letter J plus 1 in this case
4 in front and then I would exactly get
this additional descent and just putting
a letter for causes problems because now
we have two fours but then we just move
everything up once and we won't changed
the relative position of of the other
letters and so these polynomials where
we restrict to permutations that start
with a certain letter we call the Ju
Larian polynomials and what we've just
essentially seems that the H star
polynomial of such a half-open unit cube
where we removed the first J hyperplanes
is exactly that J you Larry in
polynomial the AJ plus one for allowing
polynomial on D plus one letters okay
and so essentially was the same trick
that we've just seen inserting a first
letter grantee and Becca have shown a
recursion for this J or Larian
polynomials which actually gives gives
you this here and now again if you think
about back about this lemma from savage
basanta and Fisk this exactly the
recursion that we had so by induction we
now see that this J or Larian
polynomials also form an interlacing
sequence also used and actually much
more generalized by savage and peace on
time and so as I said in the beginning
so we have to first understand for to
understanding the song talks first and
they have to understand this half of
apparel fibers and once you understand
those we send them all up and I've shown
you how how this goes for half of unit
cubes and it turns out that for half of
power pellets is a non-negative linear
combination of this unit use so in total
it will be a non-negative linear
combination of this unit cubes and in
fact we can give an interpretation for
these coefficients and now since those
Alerian J alluring polynomials where an
interlacing sequence we obtained that
it's rebooted
okay so if you look at the air happening
of this onatopp then what you
essentially do you take well you sum
over all independent sets of you're
generating vectors and then you do yeah
but like in this case it's it's a
different community or interpretation so
you actually count the number of labs
points and so in open parallel pipettes
and yeah so also some may Troy
interpretation comes in there so it's a
independent set but it's like the
internally passive elements of a basis
okay so and now let's let's turn to
dilated lettuce polytopes so for that I
I want to introduce an operator on on
formal power series which also has been
used by other people before so what we
do so imagine you have a formal power
series then what I want to do is for a
given integer R and a number between 0
and R minus 1 I just want to pick all
the terms that are where the exponent is
congruent I model R and then what I do
to the exponent well I just like do n
minus I divided by R so kind of I forget
that this was a multiple of our
yeah so this this I the idea is to
decompose the polynomial into well I
pick just every our term as an example
so R equals two and we have this
polynomial here so what I do for F 0 I
take every term where the exponent is
divided divisible by 2 so in this case 1
+ 5 T Square and T Square like I just
divide the exponent by T and for F 1 I
take well all the odd terms so 3t 73 to
the 3/5 and I forget the T and here well
I take away 1 T and divide by 2 and here
take away 1 T and divide by 2 half does
this creepy composition so explain what
F 0 is so f 0 should be F R comma 0
okay so and now as an observation so if
we have such a lattice polytope P and we
look at the general what what is the
generating series of the arts dilate of
such a polytope well I can take the
generating series of my original
polytope and I'll just pick every earth
element then I will get exactly this
generating series of the earth dilate
and now if one does some calculations
and that's what back and stable and it
then from this observation one can
express the HDI polynomial of the our
stylet of P in a nice way that involves
H star polynomial of the original
polytope so we take the original polytop
multiplied it was 1 plus D and so on the
D plus 1 and then take the every arts
term of it and so I don't write down the
the calculations because it's really
just modulo calculus I like an
equivalent way of writing it down is in
this form here and you have to explain
what all these terms mean
so with H I mean the H star polynomial
of the original polytope and these ace
here are I take this polynomial the
second factor from before to the D and
take the every ice term only now so what
we have is like a linear combination of
these ad s and sometimes also T appears
where the coefficients are also
polynomials
okay come again like I don't know and
what what do you mean that activity for
product of departures maybe not quite
but like yeah I mean like yeah it's not
hard to calculate that I wouldn't see
the exact parallel okay and so it turns
out that these polynomials have profile
also like this really nice recursion and
they're far well as I said remember this
matrix the induction again we get that
this is an interlacing sequence of
polynomials and because all these
polynomials have only non-negative
coefficients you can also see that this
sequence is interlacing so what did I do
here
well for example ad R comma R minus 1
interlaced ad R comma 0 but since all
coefficients were non-negative meaning
that all zeros were negative I can also
bring this to the other side so to say
by multiplying was T so I get this new
interlacing sequence and so this to
recall so we saw that this it's the hwo
me enough to a stylet and now what
happens if R becomes thick so what what
happens then what happens to the age our
eyes the coefficients here well if R
becomes bigger than the degree of H
which was the degree of the original
polytope then I pick at most one term
right because I pick every ass term so I
can pick only one term but this means
that the that HRI will be always like
just a real number and not a polynomial
if I just pick one number
engines by Stanley they start putting up
the coefficients of the original
polytope were on non-negative you get
that HRI is a non-negative integer when
R is bigger than the degree and since
the this these terms here formed an
interlacing sequence it follows that the
H star polynomial after our stylist is
rebooted
okay so and maybe as some concluding
remarks so very similar techniques apply
to other situations so for example plant
in Baker so what why they studied
actually these these generalized or
Larian polynomials was because they were
looking at barycentric subdivision of
simplicial complexes and so Surbiton
vasanta were looking at s or Larian
polynomials so another generalization of
alarians polynomials which actually
exactly a star polynomials of s lecture
halls simplices solium solos was looking
at edit our polynomial simply sees worse
numerous systems and also they're a very
similar recursion comes out and as a
yeah so these recursions and similar
equations appear all over and i invite
you to find maybe your own nice
polynomials and try out whether may be
some similar recursion comes up here
[Music]
[Applause]
maybe what my suffered we should do the
time for the question but I think I
should just line of stipulation
questions or comments concerning your
last result about the dilation so if R
satisfies at least like degree of the
polynomial is the arc dilate does have
24 hours i'll eight like size twice and
nice property like IDP or
or something yeah can we strain out the
residing here at least to mention that
it's a decent way die just what's the
suicide pact wounds so if you die late
by a factor larger than the dimension of
what I think what if I place that
dimension by a degree of thirty if you
start in light of this recent here for
you that I actually don't know lien no
no no I don't know that's interesting
question
so he said maybe like the largest class
would you think that this is true or
discussed and I said no I think for very
ample we also don't know the model we
don't know we know it's not like okay if
yeah yeah but there is explicit examples
what do we know that racism non-blocking
it explicit examples I see do you know
it's the class of polytopes for which
this hold is like closed under in
custody some for like it's good here
no I think the whole question is very
open
I mean like it was something like even
power Piper's was only proof in 2013 you
would think like this is a super easy
example in some sense
yeah sorry okay so they put this Rio
routed at some point is it really from
then on like yes yes yes like and
pourquoi decided once
yeah so really starts like at the degree
of the polytope and it's actually a
sharp found at least one like if you I
mean like the whole thing without does
that like you might have realized it
actually only depends on that there H
star putting all the coefficients are
non-negative so you can apply this exit
to arbitrary form of power series
therefore also applies for example
what about series of certain certain
rings and yeah but like if you restrict
yourself like if you say like for
arbitrary form of a power series then
this balance actually even sharp and if
you restrict yourself to a couple
enormous done one can see that they
found this chart if the degree of the
original particle was small
other questions or comments
take a minute break under ischium 10